let's jump to the story from NBC News
secretaries of State get ready for
possible challenges to Trump's ballot
access Arizona secretary of state is the
latest to say his office is grappling
with the potential effects of a move to
block Trump from the ballot okay you got
Arizona you got New Hampshire you've got
Florida and it's going to keep happening
my friends if in October of 2024 they
announce
at least one state Donald Trump's name
has been removed for he is an
insurrectionist of the 14th Amendment do
not be surprised they've indicted him
they've indicted his lawyers this is not
above them
I think at that point
things get bad
but Tucker Carlson was saying that
they're not going to let Trump win they
won't do covet they'll start war with
Russia which we're already in but
they'll formally declare do you think
they would be beyond that it is that it
is beyond them to do this these
Democrats what they're doing now in
Arizona is they're going oh gee golly
it's such a hard question I mean we want
to be fair but Donald Trump did an
Insurrection guess we got to remove his
name and they're talking about taking
his name off the primaries this way I
think all the Republicans to drop out
because Trump is the clear FrontRunner
and if Arizona or New Hampshire or
Florida takes his name off the primary
ballot and this results in say Vivek or
DeSantis winning
neither of them will win in the general
and it will cause a major rupture and
split giving the election to Joe Biden
maybe but Chuck Todd loves Vivek I
watched that interview do you guys see
those guys Chuck like really respects
that guy I think he's like Chuck is
terrified of trump and annoyed with
Trump and is like yo this guy's actually
smart and is has a plan and he's
interesting to listen to I uh I don't I
don't get the feeling that people that
would be considered mainstream are
giving the fake any serious respect
they're claiming this week that 911 was
an inside job last weekend he was on
Chuck Todd it was pretty cool uh at
first he was a little confrontational
like combative and then Chuck started to
soften up and you can tell he's got a
lot of respect for him I think so what
do you think about uh Trump having his
name removed from the ballot I think
there is definitely not be above the
Democrats to try and do that and at
least beneath and and trust me as
someone who's had to go around the
country and fight for ballot access for
our candidates for the last six years I
mean it sucks um
but yeah I don't think it's beneath the
Democrats what do you think they'll
definitely do I think they'll definitely
try what do you think happens if in the
general October they take Trump's name
off of say Georgia Wisconsin and Arizona
I mean Trump's Trump's not going to win
but how does this country react I mean I
think it's going to be violent yeah 100
I think it's going to get violent you
think January 6 will look like a
cakewalk I believe what is a cakewalk
it's it was a game it was a game we used
to play in elementary school you would
win cakes yes absolutely yeah it was a
game we used to play in the uh and I
don't remember how we played it with the
blindfolds I don't remember I honestly
don't remember but I know that it was a
game where you won cakes people brought
cakes and then you played this game and
oh wow I don't even think violence like
that's it's like the first uh thing
that'll happen I think if just people
just start doing massive occupations of
places like that's gonna be the scary
thing you're just gonna see thousands of
souls not even necessarily violent or
angry just occupying places
I think it'll be really ugly it started
as uh get-togethers on uh slave
plantations uh where people would have
dance contests to win cake oh cool we
played it we played it in school when I
was a kid that you can't do it now
because the school is gonna say it's got
slave kind of Visions I brought up uh
Chuck Todd seeming to enjoy Vivek is
because I think this is this is
understood they're gonna remove Trump
from the ballot they're gonna stop I
mean Trump's and they're gonna try
they've already decided he's not going
to be the president we have a deep State
get through your head and they're trying
to soften Vivek on the people right now
so that they're not so upset and they
have someone to vote I don't trust I
don't trust but they don't they just
want them they just want them to suck it
up and vote for him I think he's listen
I think that uh first of all I've called
Vivek out on Twitter a million times for
a debate if you're watching this I'd
love to debate you anytime but I know
that you'll get kicked out of the uh the
primary debates if you do that I
understand is that a rule or something
yeah apparently I did not know this but
I've been I've been challenging him to
debate for a while he said some things
in the in the the debates that I take
issue with and I'd like to talk to him
at least just talk to him on my show
about it and uh and uh someone actually
posted the rnc's rules that says uh if
you uh if any candidate takes place uh
takes part in any of the unsanctioned
debates around the country they will be
immediately removed what if you guys are
just here having a conversation yeah
that would be different and I'd be okay
with it it's not a debate right yeah
it's a long-form panel I'd be down I
don't think the vehicle do it because I
mentioned him talking with Dave Smith
and he was more like well oh yeah he was
like I'm only gonna go for the real
candidates Trump yeah well you're not
gonna he's not even going to get within
10 feet of trump doesn't want it and I
said that I said you know I'm likely to
be on the ballot as a vegetarian well
yeah I guess that would change things
and and I said that the the the
Republican debate the primary debate was
just a VP interview that's really what
it was I think the Vic's great yeah um I
don't I don't think he's perfect I don't
I don't think any politician is out
there with like their actual diary you
know broadcasting their thoughts a lot
of what they say is well crafted
planning you know you go to someone like
Vivek and he runs a biotech firm and you
say what's your position on Aleppo
he's going to be like to be completely
honest I haven't thought I don't I don't
know enough about it I haven't thought
enough about it and I'd be it'd be
difficult for me to give you an answer
the fake is the kind of guy who would
say something like that on the spot but
go research it research it and then come
back and give you a general cursory
response so what that means to me is
when you ask him on these debate stages
like how do you feel about Medicare and
Medicaid he'll give you an answer but
it's like not it's not like his
specialty right so he's giving you the
political response but uh just from
meeting the guy we've had him on IRL
twice once with me once with Sheamus and
we've had him on the culture War
I mean it feels like you're talking to a
real person yeah it doesn't like we've
had politicians and I I cringe without
naming anybody you have the politicians
on the show that are playing the
politician game and it is so annoying
it's like dude don't come on this show
if you're not going to be definitive on
your positions and your answers no the
vague outright was like he's just like
chilling and I'm like what about service
guaranteeing citizenship and he's like
yeah and then we talked about the idea
that if you want to vote in this country
after you male or female sign up for the
Selective Service you get a voter ID
card right and that's it I I really like
that idea uh you don't think it's
perfect but I like the idea I I like the
idea as well I don't think that uh I
don't think that limiting voting is a
winning argument I don't think that
there's an appetite in the United States
for it you always abolish the 19th
amendment I didn't say that
so yes there is a difference between
what I want and what I think there is an
appetite for in the United States
there's a significant difference your
ideals aren't necessarily your platform
so it's I got a plan for you guys it's
really really simple let me hear it is
called the Omnibus Bill and what you do
is you write a single sentence uh or you
write a sentence that says citizens of
the United States may only vote with a
voter ID received after registering for
The Selective Service irrespective of
biological sex and then you just slide
it right in the middle of those six
thousand pages and watch them sign it I
mean problem solved you you have a point
but again I was going to read it I don't
I don't I don't support uh I don't think
that that's a good way to pass it either
I would love to see you know a return to
the idea that there are things that are
acceptable for the federal government to
legislate and there are things that are
not and it most Things fall under the
not category and that's essentially the
goal of limiting people's vote right or
the idea the idea is there are things
that people are voting on that they're
voting you know in ways that harm the
country and stuff so like I get it that
people are like oh we want to we would
like to limit the the damage that's
possible by the whims of people voting
because essentially that's what you're
talking about people people vote on
whims with emotions and I understand but
I don't think that that's something that
the right should really try to seriously
engage in because I think that it is a
total loser yeah I agree it's such a
shutdown of morale like 90 million
people will be like what the hell are
you talking even
the same people the same people that'll
say oh this is a terrible idea and blah
blah those are the same people that will
never read a goddamn book to vote like
they will go and they will vote the most
idiot for the most idiotic reasons
they'll vote because they like the guy
smile or they like you know she's
whatever they'll vote for the absolute
most awful awful reasons but then
they'll sit there and be like no I need
to have my vote counted because you know
I gotta vote for the guy with the nicest
smile because I can't be bothered that
happens all the time which is the why
that's the whole reason to say you
should limit votes yeah I think after
the TV was invented like there's a big
shift in presidential candidates became
yep drastically more attractive that's
the famous story that Nixon on radios
they said he won and on TV they said he
lost he's on TV he was sweaty that
interview is worth that debate is
awesome he was so sweaty and Kennedy
came in so cool and it's same thing with
Clinton and Clinton's first debate he
looked like a like a and then he
must have had somebody be like look this
is where you messed up this is where you
messed up this is where he messed up and
he he examined it in his second debate
dominate you know why George Bush you
know why Trump
crushes it in the debates because he's
he's not giving you that canned
political garbage sure because we're
people are so tired and sick of oh deep
water Horizon as an oil oil spill and
the executive comes out goes we're sorry
we work really hard and with your help
and assistance we will clean oh shut up
yeah we know the moment you went back
you're sweating and you're like how much
is my bonus going down and then Donald
Trump goes on stage and just interrupts
and just says whatever and it's like
well there you go I agree I agree 100 I
I definitely sympathize more with
somebody who feels like a normal person
than I can response and you know that's
my campaign's a blue collar working
class campaign who's trying to peel the
middle class so I get it 100 I like the
fact that he's 6'3 and 215. yeah yeah I
think that's that's
definitely true yeah very true thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time